okay so I was speaking about eigenvalues
and eigenvectors for a square matrix and
then I said for data for many other
applications the matrices are not square
we need something that replaces
eigenvalues and eigenvectors and what
they are is and it's perfect is singular
values and singular vectors so may I
explain singular values and singular
vectors this slide shows a lot of them
now the point is that there will be two
i don't say eigenvectors two different
left singular vectors they'll go into
this matrix u right singular vectors
will go into V there it was the other
case that was so special when the matrix
was symmetric then the left equals left
eigenvectors are the same as the right
ones that's sort of sensible but a
general matrix and certainly a
rectangular matrix we've got two sets of
well we don't call them eigenvectors
because that would be confusing we call
them singular vectors and then in
between are not eigenvalues but singular
values so here's the right Oh hiding
over here is a key a times the fees give
Sigma x they use so that's the
replacement for ax equal lambda X which
had X on both sides now we've got two
and but the beauty is now we've got two
of those to work with we can make them
all the use orthogonal to each other all
the these orthogonal to each other we
can do what only symmetric matrices
could do for eigenvectors we can do it
now for all matrices not even square
it's just this is where life is okay and
these numbers instead of the lambdas are
called
singular values and we use the letter
Sigma for those and here's a picture of
the geometry in two by two if we had a 2
by 2 matrix
so you remember factorization breaks up
a matrix into separate small parts each
doing its own thing so if I multiply by
a vector X the first thing that's going
to hit it is V transpose V transpose is
an orthogonal matrix remember I said we
can make these singular vectors
perpendicular that's what an orthogonal
matrix so it's just like a rotation that
you see so the V transpose is just turns
the vector to get here to get to the
second one then I'm multiplying by the
lambdas but they're not lambdas now
they're Sigma's the matrix of that's a
capital Sigma so there are Sigma 1 and
Sigma 2 what they do is stretch the
circle it's a diagonal matrix so it
doesn't turn things but it stretches the
circle to an ellipse because it gets the
two different singular values in Sigma 1
and Sigma 2 and then the last guy the
you is going to get is gonna hit last it
takes the ellipse and turns it again
it's again a rotation rotation stretch
rotation I'll say it again rotation
stretch rotation that's what singular
values and singular vectors do the
singular value decomposition and it's
it's it's got the best of all worlds
here it's got the rotor the rotations
the orthogonal matrices and it's got the
stretches the diagonal matrices compared
to those two those are the greatest
triangular matrices were good when we
were young an hour ago now we are seeing
the best okay now let me just show you
where they come from so how to find
these reads well the answer is if I'm
looking for orthogonal vectors the great
idea is find a symmetric matrix and with
those eigen vectors so these V's that I
want for a are actually
in vectors of this symmetric matrix a
transpose times a that's just nice so we
can find those singular vectors just as
fast as we can find eigenvectors for a
symmetric matrix and we know they're
because a transpose a is symmetric we
know the eigen vectors are perpendicular
to each other
orthonormal okay and now what about the
other ones because remember we have two
sets they use well we just multiply by a
and we've got to use well and divide by
Sigma's because these vectors use and
Vees are unit vectors length one so we
have to scale them properly and this was
a little key bit of algebra to check
that not only the v's were orthogonal
but they use are orthogonal
yeah it just comes out comes out so this
singular value decomposition which is
maybe well say a hundred years old maybe
a bit more but it it's really in the
last twenty thirty years that singular
values have become so important it's
this is the best factorization of them
all and and that's not always reflected
in linear algebra courses so part of my
goal today is to say get to singular
values if you've done symmetric matrices
and their eigenvalues then you can do
singular values and I think that we're
absolutely worth doing okay yeah so and
remembering down here that capital Sigma
stands for the diagonal matrix of these
positive numbers Sigma 1 Sigma 2 down to
Sigma are there the rank which came way
back in the first slides tells you how
many there are good good
so that's oh here's an example so I took
our small matrix because I'm doing this
by pencil and paper and and actually
showing you the yeah the singular values
so
there's my matrix 2 by 2 here the use do
you see that those are orthogonal 1 3
against -3 1 take the dot product and
you get 0 the visa orthogonal the Sigma
is diagonal and then the pieces from
that ad back to the matrix so it's
really it's broken my matrix into a
couple of pieces one for the first thing
of their value in vector and the other
for the second singular value in vector
and that's what data science wants data
science wants to know what's important
in the matrix well what's important is
Sigma 1 the big guy Sigma 2 you see well
it was 3 times smaller three-halves
versus 1/2 so if if i had a hundred by
hundred matrix or 100 by a thousand i'd
have a hundred singular values and maybe
the first five i'd keep if i'm in the
financial market those guys those those
first numbers are telling me was maybe
what bond prices are gonna do over time
and it's a mixture of a few features but
not all thousand features right so this
is singular value decomposition picks
out the important part of a data matrix
and you cannot ask for more than that
no here's what you do if the matrix is
just totally enormous too big to
multiply too big to compute then you you
randomly sample it you you yeah maybe
the next slide even mentions that word
randomized numerical linear algebra so
this i'll go back to this the the so the
singular value decomposition this is
what we just talked about with the use
and the v's and the Sigma Sigma one is
the biggest Sigma R is the smallest so
in data science you very often keep just
these first ones maybe the first K the K
or just once and then you've got the
matrix that has ranked only K because
you're only doing working with K vectors
and it turns out that's the closest one
to the big matrix a so so this singular
values among other things is picking out
putting in order the in order of
importance the little pieces of the
matrix and then you can just pick a few
pieces to work with yeah yep and the
idea of norms is how to measure the size
of a matrix yeah but I'll leave that for
the future and randomized linear algebra
I just want to mention seems a little
crazy that by just randomly sampling a
matrix we could get any see we could
learn anything about it but typically
data is sort of organized it's not just
totally random stuff so if we want to
know why my friend and the Broad
Institute was doing the ancient history
of man so data from from thousands of
years ago so he had a giant matrix a lot
of data too much data and he said how
can we find the singular value
decomposition pick out the important
thing so you had to sample the data
statistics is a beautiful important
subject and it's leans on linear algebra
data science leans on linear algebra
you're seeing the tool you know it's
calculus would be functions would be
continuous curves linear algebra is
about vectors this is just n components
and that's where you compute and that's
where you understand okay oh this is
maybe the last slide to just help orient
you in the courses so at MIT 1806 is the
linear algebra course and maybe you know
1806 and also 1806 scholar SC
on OpenCourseWare and then this is the
new course with the new book 1806 5 so
as it's a number sort of indicating a
second course in linear algebra that's
what I'm actually teaching now Monday
Wednesday Friday and so that starts with
linear algebra but it's mostly about
deep learning learning from data so you
need statistics you need optimization
minimizing big functions calculus comes
into it so that's that's a lot of fun to
teach and to learn and of course it's
tremendously important in industry now
and Google and Facebook and ever so many
companies need people who understand
this and oh NP ting 1806 because there
is this new book coming I hope did some
more this morning linear algebra for
everyone so I have optimistically put
2021 and you're the first people that
know about it so these are the websites
for the two that we have that's the
website for the linear algebra book
master mit.edu and this is the website
for the learning from data book so you
see there the table of contents and all
I'm solutions to problems lots of things
thanks for listening to this is what
maybe four or five pieces in a in this
2020 vision to update the videos that
have been watched so much on
OpenCourseWare thank you